[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
only on cbs this morning new findings
from a congressional investigation into
infant inclined sleepers finds that
fisher price
failed to ensure its rock and play was
safe
and ignored warnings it was dangerous
the rock n play was on the market for
about
10 years the consumer product safety
commission says it's linked to more than
30 infant deaths 4.7 million were sold
before a voluntary recall by the company
in 2019 consumer investigative
correspondent anna werner
got an exclusive look at the report from
the house committee on oversight and
reform
anna how was the rock and play allowed
on shelves
in the first place well good question
anthony you know these products weren't
regulated like
cradles and bassinets and now this new
report is calling out fisher price and
its parent company mattel
for selling what investigators call a
dangerous product
despite clear evidence it put infants at
risk of serious harm or
death this is outrageous
in my opinion it's criminal that's
committee chairwoman carolyn maloney
reacting to her own investigators
findings into how mattel and subsidiary
fisher-price
developed and sold the rock and play in
klein's sleeper
we have to take steps to make sure that
this does not happen
again the subcommittee's report obtained
exclusively by cbs news
says fisher-price failed to ensure the
rock n play was safe before bringing it
to market
and ignored critical warnings that the
product was dangerous
pediatricians say babies must sleep on a
flat surface on their backs
but the rock and play sleeper put
infants at an angle of 30 degrees
now the report finds when the product
was launched in 2009
there was no independent research or
even internal company research
showing it was safe for babies to sleep
at an angle
something pediatric injury expert dr ben
hoffman finds disturbing
the fact that that there was no due
diligence done
in talking to experts to even
understanding what safe sleep was and
how
the incline sleeper product operated
completely
counter to what we know safe sleep to be
the report says in october 2012 a mother
reported to the company that her
two-month-old son had stopped breathing
in the sleeper
he was revived but two months later
fisher-price was notified that a 15-week
old infant
died in the rock and play does that pain
ever go away
no no no it's been 10 years and i still
i still cry sarah thompson's 15 week old
son alexander
also died in 2011 after napping in a
rock and play
leaving without him was so hard to come
home with
a car seat in the back and no baby in it
probably the worst day of my life
thompson says she contacted the consumer
product safety commission with no result
in fact the report says it wasn't until
2018
that cpsc staff counted 17 infant deaths
and became
alarmed one writing in an email holy cow
we need to discuss this when the
commission sees this
they are going to flip but the voluntary
recall of the rock and play did not
happen
until a little over a year later because
of what investigators call
grave flaws in the u.s consumer product
safety system
in which manufacturers are largely left
to police themselves
it's supposed to be the consumer product
safety commission
and everything we've learned is
the manufacturers are the ones protected
fisher-price told us they disagree with
significant parts of the report's
findings
the company said the rock and play
sleeper was designed and developed
following extensive research
medical advice safety analysis and more
than a year of testing and review
and that it met or exceeded all
applicable regulatory standards
but chairwoman maloney says we have to
hold corporations responsible
we have to put people over profits
the thompsons are suing fisher-price and
mattel fisher-price told
us the rock and play sleeper was safe
when used in accordance with warnings
and instructions
now the acting chairman of the cpsc says
there's a provision in the law something
called section 6b
which basically means for them that it
undermines the agency's ability to warn
consumers
about dangerous products and it should
be repealed that's undoubtedly going to
be a topic of conversation today
at a congressional hearing later on all
of this meanwhile fisher-price is
recalling
other baby sleep products this morning
the four-in-one
rock and glide soother was linked to
reports of four
infant deaths the children all between
two and four months old were reportedly
put
on their backs in the soother
unrestrained and later found
on their stomachs the company is also
recalling
it's two-in-one soothe-and-play gliders
though no deaths have been reported in
connection with that product
a price official said the deaths
underscore the importance of following
safety instructions
but again tony as you know when a baby
turns over and they are this young
or they turn their head to the side or
drop their head
in that inclined sleeper they don't have
the muscle strength
to roll back over many times or pick
their head back up yeah
it's a tragedy for the family still a
mystery to me how it took more than 30
infant deaths for these products to come
off the market and more than a decade
with them on the market
i'm glad something's happening now
though anna thank you very much